when we are very concerned about certain
of our physical features
a nose that is stubbornly a bit too
large
eyes that are slightly too far apart
hair that is not as lustrous as it
should be
we miss an overall point about our
relationship to our appearance
how beautiful we feel has nothing to do
with the objective structure of our face
or body it isn't what we look like that
counts it's how we feel inside
our self-assessments are in the end
solely based on our relative degrees of
self-love and
self-contempt
there are people of ideal proportions
and exceptional beauty who cannot bear
what they see in the mirror and others
who can contemplate a less than svelte
stomach or are no longer so supple kind
of skin with indifference and defiant
good humor at a tragic extreme there are
heartbreakingly fine looking people who
starve themselves to ill health and
eventually die out of a certainty
immune to every logical argument
of their own unsightliness
we are surrounded by industries that
seek to help us improve how we look
dietitians who are on hand to reduce our
waistlines aerobic teachers who offer to
tone us
beauticians who will equip us with
foundation and mascara
but however well-meaning their efforts
they fail completely to grasp the
sources of a healthy regard for one's
own appearance
the issue is not whether we look
extraordinary today but whether or not
we were once upon a time when we were
small and defenseless
before the judgments of those who cared
for us
sufficiently loved our essence this will
decide whether our appearance can later
on be a subject of negligible concern to
us or not the truly blessed among us are
not those with perfect symmetry they are
those whose past affords them the luxury
not to give too much of a damn whatever
the mirror happens to say the way to
help someone feel beautiful
is to not compliment them on their looks
it is to take an interest in and delight
in their psychological essence
we know that the more comfortable we
feel around someone the less effort we
will make about how we appear and
conversely the more anxious we are about
the judgment of others
the more our reflection has the power to
horrify us
the issue is never that of our
appearance
it is about our sense of our
vulnerability to humiliation
when we meet people who are perpetually
sick with worry that they are not
attractive enough
we should not rush in with physical
compliments this is only to foster and
unwittingly reward an aggravating
criterion of judgment
we should learn to spot the wound in
their early relationships that have made
it so hard for them to trust that they
could matter to others in their basic
state
and that therefore perpetually evokes
them in an unflattering self-image
they are not ugly per se
they were when it mattered left
painfully unloved and ignored to an
extent that they are liable never to
have recognized or mourned adequately
their arrival in the world did not
delight a few people as it should have
done and therefore need compassion
sympathy and emotional validation
far more than they will ever require the
tools of outward beautification
feeling ugly
stems from a deficit of love
never of beauty
one of the trickiest tasks we ever have
to face is that of working out who we
really are this book is designed to help
us create a psychological portrait of
ourselves with the use of some unusual
oblique entertaining and playful prompts
click the link on screen now to find out
more